change wives yeah Davina Anja lives
change organizations guy beer should be
organization might change the world when
we say change lives change organizations
and change the world we really mean it
Stanford GSB equips students to do that
you first have to start by changing
yourself students are naturally
encouraged innovate we tend to attract
students we tend to attract faculty who
are not fearful of making mistakes
the fear is much more on missing out on
opportunities there's extreme commitment
to I came to change the world I'm going
to change the world what does that mean
my covers and ceases to exist GSP
encourages you to take risks broadens
your perspectives on how to influence
how to lead I learn to be a critical
analytical thinker I understand the
global context of management research in
governance that we're doing it shows up
in Sec discussions is used by companies
in deciding how they design their
compensation programs how they want to
structure their board of directors this
is not a school where we're simply
training leaders for the domestic
economy the GSB I can use virtually the
whole world while standing at this place
and film directors bankers and private
equity consultants renowned leaders from
around the world a Nobel Prize winner
it's really a transformational
experience change lives change
organizations change the world I just
expected going at top business school
that everyone is going to be super
competitive with each other it's not
like that at all going through the
leadership curriculum has really helped
build my confidence and my ability to
manage high-performing team I graduated
from Stanford Business School and 2002
authentic leadership especially the way
it's used at Stanford being self
reflective self-aware and mission driven
that ability to to see myself and be
true to myself truly like a couple years
I spent Stanford Business School have
helped shape what I do as a global
leader change lives change organizations
change
if there was no extent for graduate
school of business of Beno Nike it was
in the Entrepreneurship class the Frank
Shallenberger talked that I wrote the
paper that really became the blueprint
for Nike the opening of the knight
Management Center represents a giant
leap forward for the Graduate School of
Business through curriculum reform we
now provide a very unique management
education experience it is experiential
its transformative it's individualized
personalized and now we have the
physical facility to put them in the
night center really demonstrates
teaching and living responsibly with
concerns for sustainable design this
place with so much more than a physical
facility so here I'm standing on the
edge of a town square next to the
Arbuckle cafe that about to community
court you can walk by at ten o'clock at
night and we will see students and then
the future in front of your eyes
everything on campus is within walking
distance of everything else the
university as a whole is a giant
resource to the students the physical
space grounds us enabling the ideas that
are generated here to go way beyond the
walls black Medical Center
I'm really interested in
entrepreneurship and innovation
interview clean tech space we working in
tourism improve private equity combining
business medicine Stanford GSB
using the individual's ability to affect
change make a difference in the lives of
you know hundreds millions of people the
cornerstone of our new campus reads
dedicated to the things that haven't
happened yet and the people who will
bring them up and I think that in a
nutshell captures the essence of the GSB
for sure your dream dream on a world
scale I can do whatever I put my mind to
change lives change organizations and
change the world
[Music]
[Music]